l'exemple catalan peut-il inspiré les
français c'est en tout cas le constat
qu'on pourrait faire en voyant la montée
du régionalisme de plus en plus présent
en france notamment dans les territoires
qui ont su conserver un minimum
d'identité la corse en tête de liste ou
le processus et le plus poussé sur le
plan politique déjà la coalition
nationaliste est au pouvoir à
l'assemblée régionale est aujourd'hui
l'île bénéficie d'un statut particulier
elle se charge de ces tâches
administratives et détient des droits
étendus en matière de transport
d'éducation et de protection des
monuments historiques
pourtant les français sont contre l'idée
d'une corse indépendante selon un
dernier sondage
hélas trois français sur quatre rejette
toute possibilité d'une sécession corse
une région qui n'est pas la seule à
s'identifier sur le plan politique
l'alsace suite à son intégration forcée
dans une région grand est et deux
départements du bas-rhin et du haut-rhin
ont décidé de fusionner pour créer une
collectivité européenne d'alsace qui
verra le jour le 1er janvier 2021
un stratagème pour pouvoir sortir de la
région grand-est puisque 66% des
alsaciens sont favorables à cette idée
si on devient cartographier cet élan
régionaliste voici ce qui en ressort en
dehors de la corse et l'alsace on y
trouve la bretagne le pays basque et
plus globalement l'occitanie et la
savoie
c'est plutôt sur le plan culturel que le
régionalisme s'affirme dans ces régions
d'abord avec des panneaux de
signalisation bilingue par exemple ou
encore avec le développement des études
et des manifestations régionaliste dans
les écoles les langues de la région sont
encore enseignées même si elles sont
optionnelles cela traduit l'expression
de plus en plus vive de l'identité
provincial voulue par certains
d'habitants l'exemple catalan inspire
certaines régions françaises s est monté
régionaliste montre peut-être l'absence
de reconnaissance des particularités
locales dans l'expression de l'identité
nationale